[Música]
ae
e deus
meu deus eu escolho deus eu escolho ser
amigo de deus eu escolho cristo todo
tira o chão e pra minha vida agora eu
vivo a vida de deus eu escolho deus eu
escolho ser amigo de deus eu escolho
cristo tanto te chamo rita minha fita o
que o pt eu escolho de escuro pico tinta
[Música]
fugiu mesmo dono do sétimo propriedade
recebe região numa mesma do seu mário
covas libelo meu deus meu deus que é
isso meu deus que deus me dê poder me
leva a pagar se deus que o espírito
santo me dá me ajuda meu deus o que é
isso
bush
eu estou ficando é doido meu deus meu
deus do céu eu estou ficando doido nunca
mais assisti o filme terror nunca mais
que 16 filmes de terror
um camarada meu deus nunca mais